okay so the topic of this video is going
to be chromosomes what are they the
basics of them they're structure so what
you see in the picture these kind of
rainbow color ghostly images these are
highly magnified pictures of chromosomes
so let's go ahead and learn more about
them so when we look at a chromosome we
look at a quick definition it's simply
just like a tightly coiled ball of DNA
that just so happens to resemble the
letter X now we're going to go into more
details on that in just a moment but
chromosomes form like you see in the
animation when a cell splits when one
cell splits into two well that's when
chromosomes form you might know the cell
division process called mitosis well
that's where cells split in half and
during the process of mitosis is when
chromosomes form now this video is not
going to discuss the steps of mitosis I
have another video for that if you if
you wish but that's when chromosomes are
formed is during the mitosis process
when chromosomes are there excuse me
during the mitosis process when cells
are dividing
so there's two parts to a chromosome and
here we have just a very standard
drawing of an X shaped chromosome all
chromosomes are pretty much X shapes
you're even going to hear of the
chromosome known as the Y chromosome it
too is X shaped well there's a reason
chromosomes generally have an X shape to
them because there's two halves to them
there's a left half and the right half
and we call these two halves chromatids
like you see in the picture there's a
left chromatid and there's a right
chromatid now there's also a location in
the middle where the two chromatids
connect with one another that's the
second part I want to mention called the
centromere and so when when the two
chromatids overlap with one another you
get this X shaped appearance now the
centromere is not always in the middle
sometimes it's near the top sometimes
it's in the bottom sometimes it's lower
down but that's generally the diagram
right there is what you see for a
general structure of a chromosome
but when we see pictures like this this
is these are two pictures of what is
called a karyotype and these are
pictures of a bunch of chromosomes a
karyotype is a picture of an
individual's chromosomes that they
possess inside of their cells and the
reason we might want to obtain a picture
of a person's chromosomes is it helps to
identify the gender of a person and it
helps to but more importantly it helps
to identify if a person has any
chromosome defects you know there's
other ways to figure out the gender of a
person but when it's when it's come when
you're trying to diagnose and identify a
possible chromosome disorder it helps to
have a picture of a person's chromosomes
well first of all it's let's look at how
we've determined the gender of the
individual first when you look at this
karyotype you see that the chromosomes
are numbered chromosome number one is
bigger chromosome two is a little
smaller chromosome three is a little
smaller chromosome four is a little
smaller and all the way down and then we
get to the final pair and these are
called the sex chromosomes and what
we're going to look at notice the
flashing yellow box I have that flashing
yellow box surrounding what is known as
the xx chromosome combination whenever
you see the final pair of chromosomes
that are equally sized look in that
picture right there in the flashing
yellow box those two green chromosomes
are equally sized that's what we call
the xx chromosome combination and that
identifies that the gender of the person
is a female look at the bottom karyotype
notice the flashing yellow box we see a
large X chromosome and a short stubby Y
chromosome this is what we call the XY
combination whenever there the the
chromosome the final pair of chromosomes
differ in size this is what we call the
X Y chromosome combination and this is
going to identify a male
and so whether it's a male human whether
it's a female human genetic Allah normal
chromosomal normal human being is going
to have 46 chromosomes we're going to
talk more about that as this video goes
on
so the reason for this picture is this
picture again shows a karyotype and it
shows that humans have 23 pairs of
chromosomes chromosomes 1 through 22 in
the picture are labeled autosomes and
then you have the 23rd chromosome which
is labeled the sex chromosomes so in
humans chromosome 23 determines our
gender determines our sex the other
chromosomes chromosome 1 through 22
these are called autosomes and these
help determine other traits besides
gender so the the gene for hair color
the gene for height the gene for your
blood type these are on the other
chromosomes these are on the autosomes
but whether or not you're going to be a
male or female that's on chromosome 23
the sex chromosomes
where we have a doctor performing a
ultrasound on a pregnant woman when the
doctor says you know I'm seeing
something that concerns me a little bit
I think we should consider a karyotype
and the the soon-to-be mother says oh no
is it serious well the doctor says you
know it's hard to know once we examine
the baby's chromosomes will have more
information so during the normal
ultrasound procedure if the doctor
identifies something abnormal perhaps
they're going to want to examine the
chromosomes of the baby but how do you
get the chromosomes of the baby after
all the baby is not born yet
well here's what you would do the doctor
might say I'm going to insert this
needle in into the womb and suck up some
of the fluid inside of that fluid of
course the doctor is going to be very
careful not to poke the baby with the
needle but inside of that amniotic fluid
are going to be cells that the baby has
shed and then we gun we can suck up
those cells and analyze the chromosomes
in those cells so now that the doctor
has sucked up some of that fluid those
are the cells that are in that fluid
that came from the baby can now be
examined so now that the cells have been
obtained chromosomes can be seen in
photographs on photographed underneath a
microscope
and so here we have a microscopic
picture of what the chromosomes might
look like now notice nothing is orderly
nothing is organized the chromosomes are
all just kind of randomly scattered in
this picture
however we look what the lab technician
can do the lab technician will simply
match and arrange the chromosomes into
pairs there's two chromosome number
eight the lab technician will kind of
organize them next to one another to
chromosome 15s to chromosome 20s and so
now now the karyotype can be analyzed to
see if something is wrong let's show you
an example of what some karyotypes might
look like if there are errors
here's a chromosome condition known as
Down syndrome this is a karyotype
showing a boy a male with Down syndrome
so if I were to ask you first of all to
find look over the chromosomes and find
something that doesn't look right find
something that's wrong I hope your eye
stops on chromosome number 21 if you
look at chromosome number 21 notice how
there are three chromosome 21s that's
not normal there's only supposed to be
two chromosome 21s because we have two
parents you're supposed to inherit one
chromosome from mom and one chromosome
from dad for a total of two chromosome
21s
this person has three now this video is
not going to discuss you know some of
the physical features and symptoms and
diagnose and diagnosis and prognosis for
Down syndrome if you want to learn that
you can search YouTube for other videos
but if I were to ask you to write the
notation the chromosomal notation for
Down syndrome well the first thing
you're going to write is how many total
no chromosomes does the person have
while a normal person is 46 but this
person has one extra for a total of 47
the second thing you're going to tell me
is what sex chromosomes do they have
well that depends on if it's a male or
female if it's a male has the X Y if
it's a female it has the X X in this
example you can see the X Y and the
third thing you're going to tell me is
what's missing or what's extra well this
person is not missing any chromosomes
this person has an extra chromosome 21
and that's what the plus sign means the
plus means they have an additional 21st
chromosome if they were missing a 21st
chromosome it wouldn't be a plus sign
it'd be a minus sign so there's a few
examples I want you to try on your own
so if we were in class I would give you
and your neighbor 30 seconds to discuss
this go ahead and and try to figure out
the notation for Turner syndrome pause
the video I'm going to show the answer
in three two one
okay so there's where the error is this
woman and it is a woman because there's
no y chromosome but this woman only has
one X chromosome so I hope you wrote
this for the notation 45 means they have
45 total chromosomes you could either do
a single X like you see on top or an X
with a zero like you see on the bottom
and then the last thing is again what's
missing or what's extra in this case
they're missing a chromosome 23 so minus
23
again if we were in class I would have
you work on this with a neighbor right
the notation from cows syndrome pause
the video I'm going to go over the
answer in three two one
so I hope you found the error chromosome
13 there's not supposed to be three
chromosome 13 so I'm supposed to be two
and so I hope you said 47 because this
person is 40s has one extra chromosome I
hope you said X Y because this person is
a male and I hope you said plus 13 the
plus means extra chromosome 13
alright here's the last one I want you
to try again pause the video and write
the notation for Klinefelter's syndrome
I'm going to go over the answer in three
two one
so there's the there's the error there's
the there's where's where the mistake is
chromosome 23 and I hope for the
notation you said this right here 47 X
XY plus 23 47 means that this person is
47 total chromosomes X X Y tells me the
sex chromosomes that the person has the
plus means they have an extra and the 23
means they have an extra chromosome 23
again this video is not really going to
discuss all the symptoms and the
prognosis of living with Klinefelter's
syndrome or some of those other ones if
you're interested pause the video and do
a quick search of some of the other ones
so let's get back to the notes here
there's two big broad categories of
cells that are known as diploid cells
and haploid cells and we look at this
picture this is a karyotype of a diploid
cell and what diploid cells are is they
are cells with the full or the complete
set of chromosomes notice how there's
two chromosome ones and two chromosome
twos and two chromosome threes
two of everything because we have two
parents you inherit one chromosome
number one from your mother one
chromosome number one from your father
and so in diploid cells when you examine
a karyotype the chromosomes are paired
to chromosome tends to chromosome 20 s
and so in humans now not every species
has 23 pairs of chromosomes for a total
of 46 but that's art that's the human
normal chromosome number 23 pairs of
chromosomes for a total of 46 diploid
cells are also in a category of what is
called somatic cells somatic means that
they are non sex cells
so diploid our nones are non sex cells
somatic cells are diploid diploid our
somatic and examples of non sex diploid
cells skin cells muscle cells and nerve
cells red blood cells white blood cells
brain cells the vast majority of your
body is made up of somatic non-sex
diploid cells these are the cells that
divide by the process known as mitosis
again this video is not going to go into
mitosis I have another one if you want
to watch that but in general I want you
to know these truths about diploid cells
watch how the picture changes watch how
the picture changes because I'm going to
show you what a haploid karyotype looks
like watch how the picture changes watch
three two one
I hope you see a big difference between
the picture on the previous slide and
this one
this picture shows haploid cells haploid
cells only have half the total number of
chromosomes the chromosomes are not
arranged in pairs and haploid cells are
what we call gametes gametes are sex
cells and gambits are the only cells
that are haploid in animals we're
talking about sperm cells and egg cells
in plants you could throw in pollen to
that discussion but notice how in
chromosome 11 there's only one
chromosome 11 chromosome 9 there's only
one chromosome 9 so us gametes which are
sex cells
Firmin egg are haploid sperm and egg
cells are created and pollen scuse me
sperm egg pollen these are cells that
are created by meiosis during the
process of meiosis the chromosomes
number is reduced by half that means
they're in the process of meiosis a
sperm cell will start with 46
chromosomes but be reduced to 23
chromosomes we're going to go over that
in just a moment
so here we have a silhouette of a man
and a woman and it says how do humans
get 46 total chromosomes well I have 46
chromosomes and if you're watching this
video chances are you have 46
chromosomes also how did we get 46
chromosomes well in moms ovaries she has
a bunch of egg cells and every egg cell
contains 23 chromosomes egg cells are
haploid in dads testes are millions and
millions of sperm cells and each sperm
cell is haploid and has 23 chromosomes
so on that one magical night when the
egg and sperm get together they fuse and
that creates over the course of nine
months a child so here we have a
silhouette of a child saying I'm half
mom and half dad so that's how humans
get our 46 chromosomes
well if we kind of take a moment and be
a little silly here here we have a sperm
cell and the title says that one magical
night sperm cell finds the egg cell
fertilization occurs so here we have a
little drawing of an of a female egg
cell with 23 chromosomes in the nucleus
and swarming that female egg cell here
we have five sperm cells there's 23
chromosomes in the nucleus of that first
sperm cell on top 23 chromosomes and
that other nucleus of the sperm cell 23
in that sperm 23 in that sperm all the
sperm cells have 23 chromosomes but only
one sperm cell is actually going to
fertilize that female egg cell so watch
our animation in our animation only the
head of the sperm cell enters and then
fuses with the nucleus so the 23
chromosomes in the nucleus of the egg
for a fuse with the 23 chromosomes in
the nucleus of the sperm and that
creates a fertilized egg by the name of
a zygote so a zygote marks the beginning
of all of our lives a 46 chromosomes
cell known as a zygote
well over the course of months of the
course of nine months that zygote is
going to divide by mitosis so watch our
animation here's our one fertilized egg
known as a zygote divides into two the
two cells become four the four cells
become eight each of them with 46
chromosomes the eight becomes 16 16
becomes 32 and so on and so on nine
months later a baby is born but again
how did that child get 46 chromosomes 23
from Mom's egg cell 23 from dads sperm
cell
so here we have just a nice side-by-side
compare and contrast pause the video if
you want a chance to look at this in
more detail a diploid karyotype on the
Left where the chromosomes are in pairs
and a haploid karyotype on the right
where the chromosomes are just singles
so as we wind up I wind down this video
if we were in class I would have have
you turn with your neighbor and try to
answer these six questions right here
but pause the video I'm going to go over
the answer I want you to analyze this
karyotype of a rapt notice there are 21
pairs of chromosomes rats have 21 pairs
of chromosomes humans have 23 pairs of
chromosomes but answer these six
questions I'm going to go over the
answer in 3 2 1 so I hope you can see
the gender of this rat it's a female
number 2 the number of chromosomes in a
somatic cell somatic cells are diploid
diploid means the complete set well if
there's 21 pairs the complete set is 42
chromosomes how many in a skin cell 42
because skin cells are examples of
somatic number 4 how many in a gamete I
hope you said 21 gametes are haploid the
definition of haploid means cells with
half the total number of chromosomes 21
is half of 42 number 5 how many in a
diploid cell I hope you said 42 because
diploid cells are somatic somatic cells
are diploid and finally number 6 in a
sperm cell now I know this is a picture
of a female rat but you know ray if
males and females we have the same
chromosome numbers a human male a human
female that we each have the same
chromosome numbers same with rats
so rat species they will have 21
chromosomes in their sperm cells let's
try another one of these
here's a gorilla karyotype so same type
of questions from just a moment ago
pause the video and try to answer these
six questions notice that gorillas have
24 pairs of chromosomes I'm going to go
over the answer in three two one
so first of all I hope you can see it's
a male but I didn't ask you in this in
this grouping of questions but number
one the number of chromosomes in a
haploid cell I hope you said 24 because
haploid means half the amount well if
there's 24 pairs like the picture shows
that's a total of 48 chromosomes half of
48 is 24 number two how many in a gamete
a Gami is a haploid cell gametes are
haploid haploid haploid cells can are
gametes so again it's the same question
just worded differently number one and
number two number three how many
chromosomes in a muscle cell muscle
cells are examples of diploid somatic
cells which means they have the complete
full Mount 24 pairs is a total of 48
chromosomes how about number 4 in a
zygote zygotes are diploid zygote zygote
is formed from a sperm combining with an
egg so you add the sperm add the egg
together you get a diploid zygote cycle
it's our diploid in this case it's 48
number 5 in an egg cell egg cells are
haploid again I know that this picture
shows a male but still again females
female gorillas also have 48 chromosomes
and in their egg cells would be 24
chromosomes
number six how many in a somatic cell
well that's really the same question as
number three a muscle cell is a somatic
cell so number three and number six are
really the same question just worded
differently somatic cells are diploid
and have the full amount of chromosomes
so as we wind down again pause the video
and try to answer these questions now
there's actually 1 through 7 right here
but in a moment there's a few more
questions on the on the Kobe quiz here
so go ahead and pause the video try to
answer these questions if you're in my
biology class bring your answers to me
before a school or after school I'll be
happy to check them for accuracy here's
1 through 7 pause the video but I'm
going to show you here's the here's the
rest now
so here's the rest of the questions
number 8 through 12 again pause the
video and try to work these out and good
luck